hello everybody
i'm honored to be here uh to talk to you
and what i'm going to talk to you about
today is
luck and justice and the relation
between them
some years ago a former student of mine
called me to talk about his daughter
it turns out his daughter who was a high
school senior was seriously
interested in applying to swarthmore
where i taught
and he wanted to get my sense of whether
she
would get in uh swarthmore is an
extremely
hard school to get into so i said well
tell me about her and he told me about
her you know what her grades were like
her board scores her extracurricular
activities and she just sounded like a
superstar wonderful wonderful
kid so i said she sounds fabulous she
sounds like just the kind of student
that swarthmore would love to have
and so he said well does that mean that
she'll get in
and i said no there just
aren't enough spots in the swarthmore
class
for everybody who's good there aren't
enough spots at harvard or yale or
princeton or stanford
there aren't enough spots at google or
amazon or
or apple uh there aren't enough spots
at the ted conference there are an awful
lot of good people
and some of them are not going to make
it
so he said well what are we supposed to
do
and i said that's a very good question
what are we supposed to do
and i know what uh what colleges and
universities have done
in the interest of fairness what they've
done
is they've kept ratcheting up the
standards
because it doesn't seem fair to admit
less qualified people and reject better
qualified people
so you just keep raising the standards
higher and higher
until they're high enough that you can
admit only the number of students that
you can
uh fit uh and this violates
a lot of people's sense of what justice
and fairness
is uh people in american society have
different opinions about what it means
to say that some sort of process is just
but i think there's one thing that
pretty much everyone agrees on
that in a just system a fair system
people get what they deserve and what i
was telling my former student
is that when it comes to college
admissions
it just isn't true that people get what
they deserve
some people get what they deserve and
some people don't
and that's just the way it is
when you ratchet up requirements as
colleges have done
what you do is you create a crazy
competition
among high school kids uh because it's
not
adequate to be good it's not adequate to
be good enough
you have to be better than everybody
else who's also applying
and what this has done or what this has
contributed to is a kind of epidemic of
anxiety and depression
that is just crushing our teenagers we
are wrecking a generation with this kind
of competition
as i was thinking about this it occurred
to me there's a way
to fix this problem and here's what we
could do
when people apply to college we
distinguish between the applicants
who are good enough to be successful
and the ones who aren't and we reject
the ones who aren't good enough to be
successful
and then we take all of the others and
we put their names in a hat
and we just pick them out at random and
admit
and admit them in other words we do
college admissions
by lottery and maybe we do
job offers at tech companies by lottery
and perish the thought maybe we even
make decisions about who gets invited to
talk at
ted by lottery now
don't misunderstand me a a lottery like
this is not going to
eliminate the injustice there will still
be plenty of people who don't get what
they deserve
but at least it's honest it reveals the
un
injustice for what it is instead of
pretending otherwise
and it punctures the incredible pressure
balloon
that our high school kids are now uh are
now living
under so why is it that this
perfectly reasonable proposal if i do
say so myself
doesn't get any serious discussion i
think i know why
i think it's that we hate the idea that
really
important things in life might happen
by luck or by chance that really
important things in our lives are not
under our control i hate that idea it's
not surprising that people hate
that idea but it simply is the way
things are first of all
college admissions already is a lottery
it's just that the admissions officers
pretend that it isn't
so let's be honest about it and second
i think if we appreciated that it was a
lottery
it would also get us to acknowledge the
importance of good fortune
in almost every one of our lives take me
um almost all of the most significant
events
in my life have occurred to a large
degree
as a result of good luck when i was uh
in seventh grade my family left new york
and went to westchester county
right at the beginning of school i met a
lovely young girl who became my friend
then she became my best friend then she
became
my girlfriend and then she became my
wife
happily she's been my wife now for 52
years
i had very little to do with this this
was a lucky accident
i went off to college and in my first
semester i signed up for a class
in introduction to psychology i didn't
even know what psychology was
but it fit into my schedule and it met
requirements so i took it
and by luck the class was taught by a
superstar introductory psychology
teacher a legend
because of that i became a psychology
major
went off to graduate school i was
finishing up
a friend of mine who taught at
swarthmore decided he didn't want to be
a professor anymore
and so he quit to go to medical school
the job that he occupied opened up i
applied for it
i got it the only job i've ever applied
for
i spent 45 years teaching at swarthmore
an institution that had an enormous
impact on the shape that my career took
and to just give one last example i was
giving a talk about some of my work
in new york and there was somebody in
the audience
came up to me after my talk he
introduced himself and said my name is
chris
would you like to give a talk at ted
and my response was what's ted
well i mean he told me and
ted then wasn't what it is now uh
but in the intervening years the talk
the talks i've given a ted have been
watched by more than
20 million people so the conclusion is
i'm a lucky man i'm lucky about my
marriage i'm lucky about my education
i'm lucky about my
career and i'm lucky to have had a
platform
and a voice at uh something like ted
did i deserve the success i've had sure
i deserve that success
just as you probably deserve your
success but
lots of people also deserve
successes like ours who haven't had it
do people get what they deserve is
society
just of course not
working hard and playing by the rules is
just
no guarantee of anything if we
appreciate the inevitability of
this kind of injustice and the
centrality of good fortune
we might ask ourselves what
responsibilities do we have
to the people we are now celebrating as
heroes in this time of the pandemic
when a serious illness befalls their
families
to make sure that they remain whole and
their lives aren't ruined by the
cost of dealing with the illness
what do we owe people who struggle
work hard and are less lucky than we are
about a half century ago the philosopher
john
rawls wrote a book called the theory of
justice and in that book
he introduced a concept that he called
the veil of ignorance
the question he posed was if you didn't
know
what your position in society was going
to be
what kind of a society would you want to
create
and what he suggested is that when we
don't know whether we're going to enter
society at the top or at the bottom
what we want is a society that is pretty
damn equal
so that even the unlucky will be able to
live
decent meaningful and satisfying lives
so bring this back all of you lucky
successful people
to your communities and do what you can
to make sure that we honor
and take care of people who are just as
deserving of success as we are but just
not as lucky
thank you